can you recall some days when you and
Mark maybe did some cold calling and
that you know I mean I've been there and
it's like you end up putting your foot
in your mouth and they can almost tell
that you're like an amateur and then
there's other times when you're not as
desperate so to speak yeah yeah when it
just flows yeah I mean well mark and I
have been desperate most of our lives so
we can totally relate to that but you
know for us we really didn't make
anything that we thought was really good
until our mid to late 20s and you know
we got our butts kicked back and forth a
million times we never did any cold
calling but we definitely you know we
were honestly we kind of just got
knocked back into a place where it was
like all right we're just going to make
some five dollar movies now and we're
going to see what happens and and we
ended up just getting one of those
really cheap movies into Sundance and
people loved it and we found that the
best thing to do is just to make your
stuff and make it as best as you can at
the level that you can make it at and it
will speak for itself it's very hard to
make something unique and new and good
and once you do that we found that the
doors open themselves for you and people
ask you to you know make more stuff I
mean by the time we made three short
films Sundance was asking us repeatedly
when are you going to make a feature and
we were like wow we just got invited
basically to make a feature because they
wanted to see that from us and you know
the industry was saying the same thing
too
you